i'm going to learn a lot from you i
think
yeah i also uh i specialize in fetish
fantasy as well
um
so i mean i don't like females though so
i mean obviously that's like knocks out
half of the population of
men but there's still a lot
something for everybody i think
oh yeah definitely that's one thing i've
learned about fetishes is that
literally
there's someone for everyone
there's a kink for everyone
oh yeah
well fetishes are
naturally our brain's way of
rationalizing something traumatic into
something pleasurable so no longer
experiences trauma is that right yeah
and it's like 99 of the population
literally
it stems mostly from childhood
experiences or um spousal abuse stuff
like that you know most cooks actually
are people that have been cheated on
or made to feel like
like they're little you know like
they're not worthy of true love
but
what i do is i try to utilize everything
that i know to make the cuck feel like
he's still
um
still deserves confidence still deserves
love still deserves everything that a
natural man would
you know and a lot of them that are
sissies and that's what they call
themselves or whatever um
most of them
it stems from childhood trauma
male normally
you know
abuses them sexually and they just
have this thing where they think that
they're like female-like you know
and um it's not true
like they don't
deserve to feel less than a regular man
um
but that's how they feel it's how they
feel and what i try to do is i don't
want them to experience that pain
anymore and so i try to get them to
realize is this really what you want or
is it something that you feel like you
deserve
um
you know like if i had the
qualifications i'd definitely be a sex
therapist probably or fetishes for
therapy i suspect you probably are a
therapist
of some sort
oh not professional of course but
yeah your your
whatever you do for people is
therapeutic yeah um you do this
professionally or just for pleasure um
both honestly um
you know uh
i've been like three years without uh
proper like identification i guess you
could say um out of a bad situation but
um
you know i i've been called a healer
to some people
how what do you describe yourself as
um i mean do you have a job a straight
job
no you you this is what i do yeah yeah
so
do you have a
a partner
i do you do i do yeah
yeah it's been a year and it's been ups
and downs
like when he first met me he hated what
i do
and so we were on and off a lot but now
he's actually came around a lot for it
and he understands that i can separate
it properly
and
knows that i'm doing what i need to do
to provide as well
and my heart is definitely in it to help
people so
it's not like i'm just trying to
make him feel like he's a [ __ ] or
something you know like this is not my
thing
but
yeah
it's a very alternative lifestyle you
guys lead so maybe he just needs to
understand or adapt
pretty much yeah because i'm not really
swaying on what i do
um i've tried that and i felt very empty
you could say is love uh a part of your
life i mean it is for you
yeah for sure that you've mentioned
yeah you it it doesn't really
impede your ability to love or be loved
right no no not at all actually if
anything it um helps me a lot more
because i understand far more now than i
ever did
what what kind of their
therapy is that term we're going to use
do you
help people with
um understanding past trauma and um
understanding if it's something that
the um
that goes into their fetishes or if it's
something that um what's a
[Music]
um
well obviously like voyeurism or
cuckolding um that's a huge one that
what is [ __ ] holding cuck-holding is
whenever a partner um when a man and
woman are together and the woman has
freedom to express her sexuality
but her partner is solely hers
and um there's variations in levels um
some of them uh
will be in chastity um which is like a
[ __ ] cage you know um
the male partner will be yes
yeah like a chastity adult yes and the
female the female partner can have
another partner yes
yeah um but he can't he cannot no
no um
some women even hold the key for the
chastity cages um they call them key
holders
and um
and
some and there's like i said there's
levels and some men that are cucks as
well um
they want their partner to be free
sexually and
um
be filled i guess you could call it um
it's whenever a man comes inside the
woman
um and then her partner will actually go
down on her after
and um
it definitely kind of seems
weird to some people but like for me
it's normal i guess you could say
um
i don't know i think my fetish part of
it is definitely the loyalty
aspect it's not the physical aspect at
all of what it is it's knowing that my
partner is willing to lay down his pride
and to um to love me fully even though
it's unfair
i think that that to me is a sign of
true loyalty
true love
that's interesting
and i know that all my fetishes do stem
from past trauma
so i'm fully aware of that and um
yeah is there any fixing our past
traumas or do we just
we learn how to cope learn how to cope
there's no fixing things that have
happened we learn how to forgive we
never forget yeah
what was your childhood like
hard
um i grew up in louisiana oh really yeah
um
you know i had my mom but she
was always working my step-dad was very
abusive to both of us sexually and
physically
um
he
by the time i was three my mom took me
to the emergency or the doctor
to see because i guess i was chronically
masturbating and at three
and uh
they said that it was a form of
self-gratification due to lack of
attention or something but truly
and she denies it to this day that uh
he would take me over to his friend's
house and um they would watch me do that
and that was the only time he was really
nice to me and so it became like a habit
like if i wanted my stepdad to be nice
to me i would do it
and um
it definitely
paved the way for who i am today
yeah and we left it when i was seven
and my mom
again was working all the time and i
just she wasn't around very much she
would drop me off wherever um
she felt was safe but i didn't know who
they were
so it definitely left a uh open wound
for like abandonment
and um
a crude
like self-identity
self-security you know
so
yeah
why are sexual relationships the
the common way that these
manifest themselves as
adults now
because as adults sex um
it's all around us
i mean we are basically programmed
you know i think by a society to um
to be very sexual in nature
you know it's all in magazines tv shows
um everywhere
and it sex releases endorphins feel good
feelings you know and whenever you're
battling like a
a mental health condition you have low
serotonin low uh norepinephrine low
dopamine
uh
outtake you know for your bodies
naturally and so when you have sex it
releases all of this this oxytocin the
feeling of love you know all these
really good things that we search for
and so um people
manifest this trauma into
um fetishes because it makes it's like a
gate like a getaway you know from all
these negative emotions and things that
you feel every day um
and it's it's just easy
really easy
and you can probably get addicted to
that oh absolutely sex is definitely an
addiction for most people yeah
yeah
are drugs part of your life
um yes they have been for a very long
time
um also another way of releasing those
endorphins and everything um i don't go
crazy i'm very managed um
but yeah sadly it is there there are
drugs that enhance
your libido right oh yeah
yeah
these crystal meth one of the ones that
you'll
play with
yeah typically when there's
typically yeah um that's a popular one
that's definitely a popular one um
you know obviously like viagra and stuff
like that helps too sure especially when
the other partner will do that as well
um
definitely a thing to have on hand
but um
yeah
what's what's the most interesting
fetish you've seen
interesting or like
fun or like
i've seen a lot of or heard a lot of
different things um tell me something oh
god
there's some that are pretty gross so
i'm not gonna lie i'll leave those out
though
but um
i say
um
there's guys that just
they definitely have an oral fetish and
um there's also guys that uh
like i said about the whole cup holding
and the whole like
they call it like eating out the cream
fire something like that but it's pretty
i think that's pretty out there to me at
least um
and then there's some people that love
pain
which is interesting because i also dom
as well
um
so i definitely see that
there's people that
i think have their pleasure and pain
receptors kind of like switched and so
the only way they can properly
experience pleasure is by extreme pain
and that one's interesting because
you never like sometimes i'm like i need
to sign a waiver because i'm not getting
sued for this you know like
but yeah
it's definitely interesting
did you have kids
i do you do you're raising them
no i'm not right now no
there was
um my mom has my oldest and my
ex-husband has my other two
um
yeah
me growing up and my mom like her mom
had died when she was 13 so she had no
idea of how to really be a mom
and i didn't really have a way of
knowing that either so i guess i kind of
figured with my mental health and
knowing
everything i know about myself that the
best thing i could give them is a chance
and i knew that with me
i didn't feel like they did have one
and um
yeah that's the pain i live with every
day for sure
how did you first get into this this
field
um
well
i was kind of thrown into it really um
i didn't have family i didn't have
anybody to stand on you know or have to
have my back
um whenever i had separated from my
ex-husband and he had my kids and
everything um
i started drinking a lot
and i ended up putting myself into rehab
after 10 months and
i went to transitional living i met
someone
great guy
and then he
put hands on me one day and i have a
very extensive pass in suicide and um
at least attempts
and i tried and while i was in a
hospital found out he was cheating and
he started using crystal
and in my stupid mind i was like well if
he sees me doing it he'll love me enough
to stop
and that was far from the truth
he started we both went headfirst in
and um
and he started getting very very abusive
both
um just physically emotionally and
sexually he was very deviant
and um he was on intensive probation he
got locked up
one day and i was at the end of a uh
a
um
eviction and i just had to figure out
how to live
and i had nobody
so i just figured out how to live
and then somewhere down the line all the
weird thoughts i would have through my
mind in my you know fantasy world
came to life
where i knew i wasn't crazy anymore that
there's actually a whole community based
on these things and is it much larger
than most of us assume
it's a whole world that we live around
every day and no one knows about
no one knows about
i i never knew it
you know um
and i just kind of
i started specializing in certain things
i already kind of figured i like
and um
you know with my artistry and everything
i i also um i do anything creative so i
started this thing called i call smoke
shows
and i use vape or bong whatever and led
lights outfits music and i create an
experience and it's something that i've
never seen anybody else do
and no one else has found either
and um
and i just
made it and i started when i came to
california i had nothing like nobody
nothing and i just made a way
and that's when i realized like
as long as you try as long as you
actually you know are willing to put
yourself out there be vulnerable for a
moment it may be hard at first but you
can make it it doesn't matter who you
are you just find something you're good
at and you do it
and somebody will love it
you know and um
and then from there i i met people with
smoke fetishes and then from smoked
fetishes i met people that were cucks um
obviously because like people would be
like oh well you know
um
like whenever you do stuff or whatever
like can i sit in a watch and i'm like
okay i don't mind that you know i like
that
and um it just kind of amplified from
there
and then the cucks
in turn sometimes they want to be domed
and then i obviously had to learn how to
use a strap-on and i have a whole new
respect for men
um y'all have it hard
like but i luckily am pretty good so
like they can't last more than 10
minutes with me so i'm like as long as i
can do 10-minute stretches i'm good
so what what kind of things do you get
into what what do you actually do
um like for fun
well i mean
professionally for i mean like okay yeah
um so um i do fetish modeling um
i do
a doming as well um
i do some sadism i guess you could say
it like um
almost torture
but like if the person's into it and i
know they're turned on like it doesn't
bother me to do things that i typically
would find inhumane
you know
but um
i don't know maybe i'm a little bit of a
sadist at heart too
but i think that kind of goes back to
like the whole trauma aspect
it's kind of giving it back to the
people that did it to me yeah you're
just under yours very understanding of
the fact that these people went through
something probably as children
yeah and this is how it manifests itself
as an adult well i went through it as
well as a child and this is kind of my
redemption
in a sense i have a saying i call the
victim often becomes the villain
it's just in my aspects i find it in a
way that's not traumatic to someone else
i find a way to do it and the person um
appreciate
what i'm doing to them
what is
your time doing this kind of work
taught you about
about humans
about me or them or just about humans in
general
about all of us
very complex creatures we are
very much so um
i have a whole
new appreciation for how the mind works
um but i also have a whole new um
almost goal
you know to help people become better
people
i guess you could say
to understand themselves more to not um
you know some people
um
like are into ddlg you know dominant
daddy little girl aspects it's almost
like a pedophilia but i say that
sparingly because
um
and ddlg i find it's better honestly for
for those men uh to have women that are
of age and are willing to
to kind of fulfill that aspect of their
minds and so that they're not out there
doing the deviancy that we all know are
so bad yeah
yeah
so i mean there's definitely fetishes to
help those kind of people um
or people that are into torture you know
like
both receiving and giving you know i
think that there was platforms that that
could um bring those kind of people
together we'd have a lot less crime
that's for sure
yeah how does religion play into
all of this i mean because
typically i'm a christian
honestly a lot of religions
you know
you know
sell the idea that we should be
we should conform and probably be
faithful and do all these things that
i think a lot of people
have difficulty with
it's very tricky it's wrong i know i
know what i do is wrong
i know that do i plan on it being a for
everything no
but i do know that if jesus walked
around with the [ __ ] and then the
thieves and the murderers that that we
should be able to reach those people too
i don't shy away from my i don't call
i'm not part of a religion
i'm non-denominational so i i just
believe in my personal relationship with
god and i know in my heart that i'm not
doing anything to hurt someone or to to
worsen something i'm trying to help
people
you know and so i don't believe that i
can't speak for everybody i can't speak
for him myself you know but in my heart
i hope that he understands my intention
and that
i'm just trying to to make a way i guess
right now
find out who i am
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you wish you the best
of luck thank you thank you very much
you